BONGINO.
BUT FIRST, MY OPEN.
♪
>> THE ISSUE, BORDER SECURITY.
THE WEDGE?
THE PARTIAL GOVERNMENT SHUTDOWN.
THE COLLATERAL DAMAGE?
FEDERAL EMPLOYEES WHO DIDN'T GET
A PAYCHECK YESTERDAY.
YET THEY REFUSE TO NEGOTIATE,
SIT FOR SERIOUS TALKS OR WORK
FOR THE SAFETY AND SECURITY OF
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
THEIR MANTRA?
THERE IS NO CRY -- CRISIS AT OUR
OPEN, POROUS BORDERS.
THEIR GOAL?
TROY DONALD TRUMP.
DESTROY DONALD TRUMP.
AND YESTERDAY REPORTS ARE AN
EVEN LARGER CARAVAN IS STAGING
IN HONDURAS, ABOUT TO CAUSE AN
EVEN GREATER BURDEN ON OUR
BORDER PATROL AND THE SYSTEM AT
LARGE.
THE PRESIDENT HAS SHOWN HE IS
CAPABLE OF NEGOTIATING.
HE HAS GONE FROM A CONCRETE WALL
TO A STEEL SLAT BARRIER, WILLING
TO GO WITH ANY BARRIER, ANY
PHYSICAL BARRIER THAT YOU CANNOT
CLIMB OVER, CRAWL UNDER, RAPPEL
OR SHOOT YOURSELF OUT OF A
CANNON OVER.
HE'S MADE CONCESSIONS FROM $25
BILLION TO $5 BILLION, FROM A
CONCRETE BARRIER TO A STEEL ONE,
PROMISING MORE PERSONNEL,
DETENTION BEDS, USING TECHNOLOGY
AND ELECTRONICS TO BUTTRESS THE
SECURITY AND MONEY TO ADDRESS
THE HUMANITARIAN NEEDS.
IN SPITE OF HIS NEGOTIATING, THE
DEMOCRATS REFUSE TO BUDGE.
BUT CURIOUSLY, THERE ARE SOME
DEMOCRATS PEELING AWAY FROM THE
RIGID, NONNEGOTIABLE STANCE OF
NANCY PELOSI.
>> WELL, I CAN TELL YOU WE'VE
HAD FENCING IN THE PAST, I'M
SURE WE WILL IN THE FUTURE.
>> THERE ARE PLACES WHERE A WALL
MAKES SENSE.
BUT THERE ARE A LOT OF PLACES
WHERE IT DOESN'T.
>> SOME FENCING, YOU'RE SAYING,
IS USEFUL.
>> SOME FENCING IS USEFUL, SOME
BARRIERS ARE USEFUL.
>> IF WE HAVE A PARTIAL WALL, IF
WE HAVE FENCING, IF WE HAVE
TECHNOLOGY USED TO KEEP OUR
BORDER SAFE, ALL OF THAT IS
FINE.
>> WELL, YOU HAVE TO SEE WHAT
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT HERE.
DOES IT CONTRIBUTE IN A SMART
WAY TO OUR SECURITY.
CERTAIN PHYSICAL BARRIERS CAN
MAKE SENSE ALONG THE BORDER, AND
IN A LOT OF PLACES YOU ALREADY
HAVE THAT.
>> I HAVE A SOLUTION.
THERE IS NO QUESTION THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS THE
AUTHORITY TO DECLARE A NATIONAL
EMERGENCY.
THE CONTROLLING CASE IS
YOUNGSTOWN SHEET AND TUBE V.
SAWYER.
343 U.S. 579.
THE CRITICAL OPERATIONAL ISSUE
IS THAT ONLY MONEY ALREADY
AUTHORIZED AND APPROPRIATED BY
CONGRESS CAN BE SPENT.
THE ONLY SERIOUS SOURCE OF FUNDS
ARE IN THE MILITARY CONSTRUCTION
BILL.
THIS WEEK THERE WAS SOME DEBATE
WHETHER THAT MONEY WOULD COME
FROM A LINE ITEM OF $13.1
BILLION COVERING HOUSING IN
AFGHANISTAN AND IRAQ OR A $13.9
BILLION LINE FOR DISASTER
RELIEF.
NOW CLEARLY, THE $13.1 BILLION
SHOULD BE THE LINE USED SINCE I
DOUBT WE NEED TO BUILD HOMES IN
AFGHANISTAN AND IRAQ.
BUT NOW EXPECT THE DEMOCRATS TO
GO FORUM SHOPPING IF THAT
HAPPENS IN CALIFORNIA WHERE THE
APPEAL GOES DIRECTLY TO THE 9TH
CIRCUS -- CIRCUIT -- IF THE
PRESIDENT DECLARES AN EMERGENCY
USING THE MILITARY CONSTRUCTION
FUNDS.
ASSUME THEY WILL WIN.
BUT ON AN APPEAL TO THE SUPREME
COURT OF THE UNITED STATES, THEY
WILL LOSE UNDER YOUNGSTOWN.
SO THE ONLY QUESTION NOW IS
WHETHER OR NOT THIS IS A
NATIONAL EMERGENCY, AND IF YOU
DON'T THINK ANOTHER CARAVAN OF
THOUSANDS MOVING IN A HIGHLY
ORGANIZED FASHION SIMILAR TO
MILITARY CONVOYS WITH AN
ADVANCED PARTY, A MAIN BODY AND
A REAR PARTY THAT HAS EXHIBITED
VIOLENCE ALONG THE WAY WITH
MIGRANTS IN ADDITION TO THOSE
FROM CENTRAL AMERICA FROM
AFRICA, PAKISTAN, YEMEN,
AFGHANISTAN, INDIA, BANGLADESH,
NEPAL AND MORE IS A NATIONAL
EMERGENCY, THEN YOU'RE OUT AND
OUT CRAZY.
THE PRESIDENT HAS BEEN SITTING
IN THE OVAL OFFICE SINCE
CHRISTMAS EVE.
HE'S READY.
IF THE DEMOCRATS AREN'T COMING
TO THE TABLE, THE TIME TO
DECLARE A NATIONAL EMERGENCY IS
NOW.
AND THAT'S MY OPEN.
IF YOU LIKE MY OPENING
STATEMENTS, YOU'LL LOVE MY NEW